hi there this is steve kaufman and i'm
doing this video in response to
um
a question raised on my blog the
linguist on language blogs by one of my
regular readers who calls himself
kaufmanist nutball but has had various
names in the past i appreciate his
comments he tends to be sometimes a
little aggressive in making his points
but
we all have our styles
but he makes the point that um
the fact that i was born in sweden and
my parents were from czechoslovakia and
spoke
german and czech at home which i heard
uh
that even though when we moved to canada
we spoke english at home
and i did forget my swedish
uh montreal is also french speaking
although i lived very much in an
english-speaking enclave and i didn't
really
have much contact with french but all of
these things helped me and so therefore
if i can speak now 10 or 11 languages
that
you know i was very fortunate to have
those conditions and therefore i'm not a
good example of of language learning in
general
he also mentions the case of susanna
from
l.a the
lady who wrote the book about about
language's music
i'm going to admit i don't remember her
last name so i don't want to
mispronounce it very delightful lady we
spoke in an interview that i put up on
my blog i'm hoping to do a video
interview with her
someone who
was born in the soviet union emigrated
to the u.s at the age of three
has lived in argentina and is very
fluent in seven languages
so the point here is that people who
have that kind of exposure to different
languages in childhood have a big
advantage therefore uh
then the question to me is therefore
what
uh i
mentioned in my book and i always
mentioned that i did have that
background as a child and that i think
it probably helped me i think it helps
people to be exposed to languages in
their childhood it makes their brains
more flexible i am sure that that is
true
however
i work very hard at languages
much harder than anybody i know
now maybe the fact that i have success
with languages encourages me to work
hard
uh however
i also know people
many people who are unilingual raised
unilingually
and become very good speakers of two
three four or more other languages
so it's it's undoubtedly and i should
add i know uh people
who grew up in a multilingual
environment and who do not become good
language learners
i know friends that i went to school
with who were in a similar situation who
had emigrated from europe at a similar
age and who essentially did not become
good language learners
a lot of for example quebecois grow up
hearing english and french and they have
two languages and my experience in the
foreign service was that they were not
necessarily better at learning chinese
or japanese than english canadians who
had been raised unilingually
i see examples here in vancouver of kids
who come here
immigrants
say from china kids are born here
they end up in esl at school because
they don't speak english well enough
to to be in a class with the other kids
although to my mind a lot of the esl is
quite unnecessary but but they have
trouble with english and they also don't
have an advantage in learning third
languages
so you know it's another one of these
things that in theory it's an advantage
but it's not a condition
it doesn't guarantee success and the
fact that you haven't had that
opportunity doesn't prevent you from
having success
the the ultimately the language learning
success depends on motivation
and so a very motivated person
regardless of their language background
in childhood will be successful in
language learning it's like a number of
other conditions that in theory are
advantages but which are not conditions
for success for example
people say well if you go to the country
then you'll become fluent
i have met
if i think of the people that i know
say in china or japan
or people that i speak to via skype here
at link
who are russian or japanese or or
spanish
and if i compare their english to the
english of many immigrants i would
almost say the average japanese chinese
russian immigrant that i encounter here
in canada
the people that i got to know
in china japan or talking about spoke
english better
than the immigrants here now i'm not
saying that all people in japan china
russia speak better but i'm saying that
those people
in those countries who have never set
foot in an english-speaking country but
who are very motivated to learn
they end up speaking better than the
average immigrant here so the point
again is that while it's an advantage to
be in the country where the language is
spoken it's not a condition
it doesn't guarantee you success and not
being there doesn't prevent success
because ultimately it boils down to
motivation
now the other thing is the other
question is well my approach to language
learning which is based on a lot of
input you know reading and listening and
vocabulary growth is that something that
only works for someone with my you know
background as a child
uh here again i don't think so uh i
always say the main thing in language
learning is to do what you like to do
but uh i think
no matter what our background is we do
have to get the language in us and
the question of when we start to speak
and how much emphasis we should put on
grammar will depend on the individual
it'll also depend on the opportunity and
you know with russian i i'm not gonna
change my social and professional life
around so that i spend the day with
russian speakers
as susannah suggests that i find a
russian to go grocery shopping with i'm
not about to do that
so therefore i'm stuck with a lot of
listing and reading if i were in russia
yeah i'd be speaking every day with
anyone that i could inflict myself upon
so
yeah i in summary then i think the fact
that i had
from a language learner's perspective an
advantageous
uh
you know background as a child has
undoubtedly i believe it has helped me a
lot
to be successful to speak 11 languages
it has motivated my or has fueled my
motivation but it's not a condition i
don't think it changes
the question of of what is an effective
way to learn
i don't think it means that people who
haven't had that opportunity cannot
learn because i know too many examples
of people who have been very successful
i think of darshan in china who is a
very popular figure uh countless people
that i've worked with canadians who have
gone to japan english canadians people
in my office
in the lumber business but who went
there as students or to teach
english and who have come back speaking
fluent japanese and they were successful
because they were motivated because they
liked the people the language they got
immersed in it
so in summary yeah it has helped me uh
cough man is nutball
but it's not a condition and i don't
think it invalidates
my approach to language learning so i
look forward to more comments thank you